bonjour j'ai lu bermeja ni merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france vous êtes en direct de
bruxelles un cas de variants au micro
n'a été détectée en belgique dans quel
état d'esprit à la communauté
scientifique et médicale belge et puis
comment réagit aussi la population entre
quiévrain
oui bonjour
il y à une inquiétude qui est présente
mais quelques jours pas à cause de ce
variant mais à cause de la remontée des
cas infectés donc depuis déjà une
semaine ou deux il ya un petit petit
emballement du politique qui qui acquit
à resserrer un peu la vis des mesures et
donc comme vous savez ils ont annoncé
vendredi la fermeture
des boîtes de nuit
limitation du temps d'ouverture des
restaurants le télétravail donc l'état
d'esprit les plus tôt surtout
dominé par par cette actualité de
l'augmentation du nombre de cas et pas
du tout encore tiré par l'arrivée de
l'eau microns il ya eu un cas détectés
qu' une personne qui n'est pas malade
donc sur ce point là il considère que
c'est tout à fait contre les voilà
on vient de l'apprendre ce mâtin israël
ferme ses frontières à tout
ressortissant étranger se mettre en
autarcie c'est une solution est ce que
l'afrique du sud est mise en quarantaine
par la communauté
internationale on rappelle
oui tout à fait c'est le retour aux
réflexes du début de l'épidémie donc les
réflexes de se protéger donc on met en
quarantaine en effet en quelque sorte
l'afrique du sud est et tous les
voyageurs qui rentrent dans le pays on
redouble de vigilance est ce que c'est
la bonne la bonne attitude ma position a
toujours été très clairs là dessus on ne
peut pas se cacher éternellement et fuir
la réalité il faut mettre en place des
mesures structurelles d'augmentation des
capacités d'accueil dans les hôpitaux de
vaccination bien sûr j'ai souvent est
toujours plaidé pour cela juste pour
qu'il y ait une sorte de cohérence dans
justement beaucoup de spécialistes en
s'interroge sur l'efficacité des vaccins
actuels vis-à-vis de cette nouvelle
souche nouvelle souche qui est
semble-t-il quand même a priori plus
contagieuse qui mute beaucoup plus rude
des vaccins justement
oui c'est une souche qu'ils appellent
souche
en anglais variante of concern donc qui
qui un peu plus qu'une souche qui nous
intéresse parce qu'en effet c'est une
souche qui montre des capacités de
contagion plus importante est que et une
certaine je dirais dangerosité plus
importante elle pourrait un peu aussi
affecté les capacités de de testing donc
c'est une souche qui montre quand même
un intérêt
plus important est ce qu'elle est pauvre
on ajoute à cette sauce c est ce qu elle
est résistante en axant
toute nouvelle souche très rare et
résistante un peu plus au vaccin le
vaccin a été fait à partir des premières
souches du corona et donc en effet on
est allé au micro il y en a eu d'autres
dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé l'epsilon
le iota et l'état sont il ya déjà eu
beaucoup de variantes ils n'ont pas été
de grands intérêts donc en effet on est
l'actuel variant qui domine c'est le
delta qui est déjà la plus infectieux
est plus contagieux que la version de
base et yamaska que l'homme mikron
prennent le dessus sur delta a bien
entendu si les six se transmet plus il
prendra le dessus donc moi mon espoir
est le message que j'aimerais faire
passer ici c'est le vaccin jusqu'à
maintenant reste plus efficace que le
fait de ne pas être vaccinés même si ça
son efficacité diminue et il faut donc
deux choses aujourd'hui vacciner très
largement surtout dans les pays où la
vaccination n'est pas encore tout à fait
disponible pour tout le monde donc il
faut pas simplement s'enfermer en europe
et ne pas penser aux restantes et il
faudrait qu'ils aient de nouveau vaccin
qui arrivent sur le marché sont des
vaccins qui sont adaptés à ces nouveaux
à ses nouveaux variants
ça veut dire que peut-être on ne sait
pas encore en tout les cas pfizer
moderna travaille dessus mais si ces
vaccins ne sont pas efficaces face à
cette nouvelle souche omicron est-ce
qu'il faut quand même recevoir une dose
de rappel en france on le rappelle ainsi
les 18-64 ans n'ont pas effectué leur
troisième injection des cils 15 janvier
lors pas sanitaire ne sera plus valide
donc sk pas un côté paradoxal se faire
vacciner sans savoir si c'est efficace
oui vous dites inefficace j'ai pas dit
non en fait on sait pas mais on
s'interroge
ok vous dites il est probablement moins
efficace jusqu'à maintenant le vaccin a
perdu de son efficacité
mais elle est toujours présente ça veut
dire qu'il diminue la mortalité qu'il
diminue d hospitalisation grave et les
hospitalisations en général donc que ce
soit donc comme il a fonctionné pour le
delta il fonctionnera probablement pour
le micro alors levac le virus
majoritaire actuellement c'est le delta
ce qui oblige à avoir la troisième bosse
donc la troisième dose on la reçoit
parce que 100% virus qui circulent en
europe c'est encore le variant delta oui
mais vous avez dit que le variant au
micro on pouvait prendre le dessus s'ils
n'étaient plus résistant et fait
timidement composent
le version au micro-ondes c'est déjà
plus qu'une cinquantaine de mutation qui
sont détectés c'est pour ça que c'est un
nouveau variant qui a l'air d'être plus
contagieux on n'a pas plus le chiffre
pour savoir quelle sera sa létalité ou
en tout cas donc ça son assassin entre
nîmes et sa méchanceté et on le saura
très bientôt
quelle est la réaction des personnes
vaccinées le virus on le sait pas encore
je rappelle le virus aujourd'hui qui
cause l'augmentation des
hospitalisations et encore le delta mais
y aller
les français tout comme les belges un
j'imagine se pose la question si on
reçoit une troisième dose de vaccin en
l'état actuel des choses pour protéger
donc contre le variant delta est ce
qu'on devra recevoir quelques jours plus
tard quelques semaines plus tard une
dose encore de rappel pour se protéger
cette fois face aux variants omicron non
l'ado la troisième dose qu'on va
recevoir sera nous protégera pendant
longtemps probablement une année je
pense j'ai plein contre le vaccin mais
même contre le vario mikron parce que
les laboratoires avec elle et les
vaccins à
technologie arn messagers on nous a dit
qu'on pouvait confectionner beaucoup
plus rapidement à nouveau vaccin contre
les nouveaux contre les nouveaux
variants mais à ce compte là ce cas pas
un décalage dans le temps entre le temps
de la conception le temps de la
production et ensuite le ton de
l'administration des vaccins à ce que on
va pas perdre du temps à ce que ce
serait pas trop tard
vous l'avez vu pour le verrions de base
vous le connaissez vraiment rien on a pu
confectionner le vaccin en une année à
peu près donc clair maintenant le virus
il est suivi par son vélo est séquencée
de façon très rapide donc le nouveau
vaccin pourrait arriver pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne lance pas déjà assez nouveau
vaccin déjà parce que le vaccin actuel
protéger contre le variant delta et
qu'on essayait de vacciner le plus de
monde je plais pour de la cohérence je
pense qu'il faut arrêter ces débats
stériles sur je me fais vacciner je me
serais pas vacciner c'est cevital de la
population mondiale soit racines et et
en europe s'est encore où le vaccin est
très disponible c'est vraiment triste
c'est désolant même qu'on ait encore des
débats sur la nécessité de se vacciner
ou pas et donc avoir une population qui
est vaccinée à 80 ou 85% nenê n'est
malheureusement pas suffisant
à bruxelles la vaccination est né à 55%
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
désolant je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
débattre il faut être cohérent il faudra
signer il faut augmenter les capacités
des hôpitaux et il faut apprendre à
vivre avec ce virus mais peut-être de
potentielles nouvelles épidémies se fait
quand même dix ou quinze ans que
beaucoup de gens nous alerte sur la rive
et d'épidémies est peut-être encore
potentiellement dans un avenir proche de
la grippe simple vous le savez comme moi
le vaccin de la grippe ne protège pas
très bien pour la grippe donc j'ai 50 60
% de protection et pourtant on le fait
pourtant le virus lui tous les ans et
tous les ans c'est un nouveau vaccin qui
est administrée et on le fait je dirais
sans grand débat pour ceux qui sont
fragiles ou pour ceux qui soignent les
personnes fragiles notamment le corps
médical donc voilà de nouveaux vaccins
vont venir il faut continuer à se faire
vacciner il faut se faire vacciner
actuellement avec la troisième dose
parce que la dose prédominant à 100%
c'est le variant belta
merci gilbert b gêné d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin anesthésiste est président de
l'absym l'association belge des
syndicats médicaux